bang bang what's going on guys
lunch money time coming to you on
wednesday while wall street's trying to
get rich
the rest of us just trying to get lunch
money right i'm here with the beautiful
and intelligent polina marinova
she looks like an elf today she's just
missing a little hat
i just said that and you copied it well
if you're gonna say that you look like
elf then it's okay for me to say it you
see how i am making sure that you won't
get mad let's get into the topics what's
going on with airbnb
airbnb has plans to lay off nearly
1900 employees or about 25 of the
company
this is interesting because there was
just a profile on brian chesky the ceo
uh it was it talked about how the
company was supposed to go public in
2020 and said he's
uh expecting a 50 revenue dip
and he's cutting his 800 million dollar
marketing budget
uh yeah so airbnb is firing 1900
employees 25
of the staff uh there's three things
that i think are interesting here one
they're supposed to go public
now they're not i just said that i
understand two
is they had a really really strong
balance sheet at one point he was
actually
uh not bragging but um you know saying
publicly that they had raised over a
billion dollars and hadn't touched it
so that the business was break even
profitable did he
was he not telling the truth when he
said that no he was but it changed
right everything changed in the last
three months so basically what ends up
happening now
is you take a business that looked like
it was super strong
but it's in travel and hospitality right
you need people to travel places
and then you've got the hospitality
angle to it and so there's uh the third
thing that i find really interesting is
airbnb's entire model actually may save
them here so if you're a hotel you
actually would own the location
and the staff right in this case what
ends up happening is
airbnb has you know hundreds of
thousands if not millions of locations
around the world
on their platform they don't own those
pieces of of property
and they don't actually employ the
quote-unquote host
all they do is they play matchmaker
between people who want to stay
and people who have the property so i
think that once it's safe to travel
again and once people start traveling
again
i do think that there will be a number
of people hosting on airbnb that will
want to make some money
given the state of this world right now
right they will
but my point is that airbnb's model
probably actually
saves them and puts them in a better
position than hotels yeah because they
don't own
all the properties yes but what are you
doing the people
don't have money to travel or or it's
not safe they're not allowed to
but on top of that then you also have
hosts who have gone out so like if
you're an enterprising airbnb
host uh you may start with hey i have a
house let me rent out my house
then you're like you know what i'm
actually gonna go get a second house let
me go get a third house a fourth house a
fifth house
and so there's people who literally have
gone and either bought or are
renting uh multiple properties and all
they're doing is they're just running
uh renting them out on airbnb and
they're making a good money like it was
a good it was actually a good business
now all of a sudden you're sitting there
like wait a second i've got six
mortgages
uh and i have no ability to actually
fill this with people how am i gonna pay
my mortgage
uh across these six properties and so i
think it's just um
you know this is the realities of what's
going on right now
uh unfortunately to see um you know 25
percent of employees laid off is not
good
uh but also um there's plenty of tech
companies that are actually benefiting
from this
uh so so i think it's kind of you know
expected yet still sad
chesky also said airbnb's business has
been hit hard with revenue this year
forecasted to be less than
half of what we earned in 2019. it's
only the first what three four or five
months what are we may we're in month
five five wow it's been five
months and he already knows this is not
gonna be what's half the year
almost oh yeah all right what's going on
what the heck is this thing xo
ae a-12 so elon musk had a new
son and that is his name
really yeah wait like is that like a
nickname or that's like the actual legal
name that
it's it's x-a-i-a-e-a-12 musk
you're joking no that's like that's like
uh
r2d2 like like when you have like we
birthed a robot
unclear how you pronounce this but
grimes his girlfriend who had the baby
clarified
everything about the baby's name except
the pronunciation
so we know what it kind of means unclear
all right
well what explain it so x is the unknown
variable
okay i think i i don't know
it says she says my elven spelling of
a.i
love and or artificial intelligence i
think she tried to
say my 11 spelling no like elven like
elf
oh okay go ahead you look like an elf
right now
go ahead okay um a minus 12
precursor to sr17 our favorite aircraft
it's not a minus 12 it's a dash oh
a12 so i messed up the a uh 11
and you messed up minus all right uh
okay no weapons no defense is just speed
great in battle
but non-violent ain't nobody great and
battle who's non-violent
yeah well obviously uh a12 is
um all right so i i saw that first of
all elon musk had a child that's the
whole point of this
uh he didn't have the child his
girlfriend did
but the best part was i saw somebody on
twitter that took two screenshots
and one was um people uh asking her
what is the gender is it a boy or a girl
and she
had a whole post about like i don't want
to put a gender on the baby
uh i think that that's for the baby to
choose what gender they are and you know
kind of that whole
talk track uh and then somebody asked
musk boy or girl and he just responded
boy so this one must have like five
boys i think he has way more children i
i think it's actually more than five
um but we'll see what's going on all
right so uh we'll figure out what's
going on with this name would you would
you ever name your child something like
that
well if i had a robot i definitely would
name it like that
guys one time we watched this robot
movie oh
chappy it's called chappy and i just
walk in the room and anthony's like
sitting like this and like
really extremely sad i don't think i've
ever seen you that sad
and it's because they attacked chappie
yeah
the robot turned into had human emotions
and they cut off his arm i was
messed up man so if you're looking for a
good movie recommendation
chappie or you can go try to figure out
elon musk's kid's name all right what's
going on with the
iss movie so nasa there were rumors but
nasa now confirms that
there's going to be a tom cruivey
uh oh are we getting a laugh attack
again all right nasa confirms that tom
cruise movie is gonna be
shot aboard the international space
station uh what i
i got a lot of questions about this
including uh
one is tom cruise gonna be go two to
course he's gonna go what do you mean is
he
tom cruise is not going to space uh i i
would bet a lot of money they're not
gonna send tom cruise to space because
you would have to have
all the training spacex will res
presumably take part as cruz
rides to the iss assuming the actor is
actually going to be the one
heading there to film on the site i
think he's going to go he's insane
you it's not a matter of uh intellectual
uh insanity it's a matter of physical
prep preparedness you would have to be
physically fit enough
like an astronaut to fly to space but do
you remember the other day when we were
talking about those uh
astronauts and they were like in their
40s and 50s so why not tom cruise
it doesn't matter what your age is
they're physically fit and trained to go
to space
it it's like it's like saying uh
hey why doesn't the three-year-old go
drive a car well like
first of all the three-year-old doesn't
have the ability to drive
what the point is of filming a tom
cruise movie
on the iss if tom cruise cannot go on
the iss
well it's all about authenticity i'm
assuming so rather than do it on like a
movie lot in uh
in hollywood let's go do the real thing
plus guess what you're doing you're
promoting their iss movie right now so
it's a great marketing tactic
for nasa well nasa uh won but also two
for the movie they're gonna sell a bunch
of money
uh they're gonna sell a bunch of the
movie if uh if people like holy [ __ ]
they really went to
the iss see when you said movie there
you really wanted to say tom cru
me what's going on with iran
it's too early in the morning for this
so iran
inflation is ravaging the currency tell
us what's going on
i mean look this is what happens when
inflation hits uh the currency goes down
in value and so they've got to print
more
in societies where there is a heavy cash
like actual physical cash usage
they start to print bigger and bigger
dollars right so
um for example the the real um
if yesterday uh a loaf of bread i'll
just use easy numbers it was ten real
and today it's 20. or a year from now
it's a thousand or ten thousand real for
that same loaf of bread
obviously you don't wanna be carrying
around you know
tens or hundreds of ten real
um you know currency so what they end up
doing is they print
larger and larger ones uh so that it's
easier to carry it around right that ten
real is now basically worthless it's
like a worth a penny
so then they start to print a hundred a
thousand ten thousand you know a million
real whatever
and so in zimbabwe the famous one is
that there's a um
one trillion dollar zimbabwe
uh physical cash i actually have one in
my wallet i carry around
um but if you get a zimbabwe bill
somebody gave it to me as a gift uh but
with iran
what's going on here is uh they're
slashing four zeros
off the face of these uh off the
currency so basically what ends up
happening is if you had a thousand read
all
uh actual hard currency now it just says
one
right okay and the whole idea is if you
just remove four zeros off all of them
then you can reset the value and you
don't have to eventually print to one
trillion
i've always wondered that why don't they
just do that instead of
continuing to print larger and larger
builds well because they look like
idiots right now
like literally they look like idiots who
cares why
what do you mean why they literally just
said to everybody okay
we're so dumb that we created so much
inflation and we have
and we have a lack of discipline in our
central banking
that we've literally have to go and
slash four zeroes off
i i i mean it's insanity like these
people
are insane and the reason remember what
you asked yesterday
what is money you're literally watching
a magic trick
these people think they're magicians but
the difference is we've removed the
curtain
and we're calling [ __ ] guys
yesterday we literally had like a
five-minute uh debate around
uh whether magic had a positive
connotation or a negative connotation no
i said that magic
has a positive connotation as an act but
the outcome is negative because you're
lying to people
and we compared it with war which in
many cases the people who conduct war
have a negative connotation of the act
but the outcome they
oh i did not understand you talking
about that part i was talking about the
magic part i think it's great
i like magic but i just want you to know
that central bankers are being
uh again the virus is showing at the
sham
the central bankers think they're
magicians and they're literally like
poof let me just
erase four zeros off the currents but
you know why i think magic is positive
why because i'm a magician okay let's go
what's going on with virtual money
one day i will i will do a magic trick
on this show and then you'll
you'll see okay so okay
so virtual money uh startups are getting
oh wait uh oh no you forgot what the
topic is already the basically startups
are raising money
virtually yeah i don't think this is a
big deal i guess to a lot of people is a
big deal
i've been doing this for five years uh
investing a lot
um virtually not meeting the founders in
person
i know a lot of people who uh that's
like blasphemy to them and they feel
like they have because they have to
because doesn't the vc have to kind of
whine and dine me before they can
give me money so they make sure i'm not
a psychopath
i mean in some cases yes but in other
cases like you're like oh my god i can't
believe
one vc wants to give me money i'll take
the money
right so it's all about supply and
demand and uh
what is the importance of being in
person versus a resume well a lot of
people just say hey look i get a better
understanding of who this person is by
actually spending time with them in
person
uh and so if now all of a sudden i've
got to make these investment decisions
over
zoom uh do i actually get a read on them
i don't see their mannerisms
it's a little less impersonal like all
of those types of things
um but but look i don't think that this
is necessarily a huge deal
um we we will see more and more of it at
the early stages
as teams go remote as investing teams go
remote
uh the reason why this i think is a big
deal is because this company
vast data i believe it's called they got
a billion dollar valuation
so they raised quite a bit of money at a
very high valuation
my guess though and i i don't know all
the details is that
uh the valuation was done
uh with um existing investors
there's probably some new investors as
well uh but like
when you're at that big of a company
it's less about like what is what do i
think about polina and it's much more
about
show me the numbers right are you
growing what's your revenue numbers like
it's more of a financial metrics
decision than it is the person
do you think that there will be any
companies brave enough to go public in
2020
yeah i mean draftkings did their reverse
takes
reverse merger right so like i i
definitely think that there will be some
companies that do it
uh definitely probably in the the latter
half of the year i'm talking about your
meat and potatoes type of ipo i'm not
talking about reverse mergers i'm not
talking about direct listings i'm
talking about your like
no but why would you but why would you
do it right now it's not a courage it's
not a courage
that's what i'm asking do we think we're
we've seen the end of the ipo for 2020
well let me ask you this question would
you run into a burning building
to save somebody okay so there's some
cases where you would run in
but well actually you wouldn't you'd
send me um
let's be serious like why aren't you in
there
that's all so accurate and then uh so
some p
some people may want to do it but the
question is if you go into an uncertain
environment let's say you go public
tomorrow and then all of a sudden
there's a
massive leg down in the stock market
down 30 percent during uncertain times
you basically just lost a bunch of your
market share right or market cap
and so it's just people whenever it gets
to be uncertain times
they really really uh get cautious we
saw warren buffett talk about that this
weekend we see airbnb
obviously kind of over rotating to
slashing staff
shoring up the uh balance sheet not
going public whatever
cool what else have you said your piece
yeah speaking of
uncertain times why is relationships
well i will tell you right now
esther perel who is like a couple's
therapist
um did this interview
and she said some really interesting
things that i thought we could talk
about today
okay so one thing she said is that she
thinks that in general when people are
living in acute stress i.e quarantine
either the cracks in the relationship
will be amplified or the light that
shines through the cracks will be
amplified
what do you think is amplified anthony
listen this isn't the today show
this is not the today's show check the
topic yeah i let you pick topics today
and i got a robot name
virtual money which you remember what it
was and and relationships what the heck
is this
i'm asking you what do you think about
living with someone in times of stress
well it depends on who the person is
like could you imagine a little
joe exotic or carol baskin that'd be a
nightmare living with you is actually
okay
it's fine except for last time we have a
problem that we need to discuss on here
we got three minutes i'm going to air
this out
last night paulina went on seamless and
she ordered
mexican food she did not realize that it
was cinco de mayo i didn't either you
wanted mexican food
so she ordered the mexican food and
we're sitting here probably around six
o'clock we're sitting here
doesn't show up 6 30 not here seven
o'clock not here 7 30 still not here
8 o'clock still not here at 5 30 it
arrived at
you ordered it at six uh okay 5 30. and
uh
and so she starts trying to call the
place and literally the line is busy the
entire time so it doesn't show doesn't
show so finally around 8 15 we're like
i guess it's not coming like it's been
you know two and a half almost three
hours
so we order from a different mexican
place
and plan starts talking to people on
seamless trying to figure out you know
what's going on
and uh all of a sudden i don't hit the
uh the send button on the second order
more than five minutes later bam the
food shows up and i was like are you
kidding me
so then i told you that could happen
that was a risk you were willing to take
so newsflash don't order mexican food
on cinco de mayo around dinner time
because it'll it basically won't show up
ever yeah we should have gotten like
american food yesterday
but no it's all right i want i wanted a
chicken quesadilla that's fine
um but we did good we we gave somebody
else the food so we're we're good
so anyway i'm curious how you guys are
navigating your relationships during
quarantine please leave a comment below
and tag me
this is not gonna turn into the today
show uh
i know that you're enjoying this but i'm
not there's gonna be people i know i
i'm prepared for the hate there's gonna
be people who don't like this
all right well while paulina is playing
uh elf
up at uh santa's uh workshop
uh the rest of us are just trying to get
our lunch money right so while she's
trying to get her
uh get rich the rest of us just trying
to get lunch money right we appreciate
you guys watching hopefully this is
helpful
leave a comment we do our best to
respond to all of them and we will talk
to you guys tomorrow
bye